la discrimination le racisme la
xénophobie
nous sommes comme ça
[Musique]
chaque génération a là l'opportunité
d'évoluer et d'apprendre à jouer bien
avec les autres
comment on fait pendant l'enfance
caen joue sans penser à la couleur du pô
les langues on joue simplement
joyeusement et puis on a pendant là dans
le sens peut-être avoir des différences
à se voir comme supérieurs ou inférieurs
différents et le travail de chaque
génération de chaque personne
si si on a la chance et de d'évoluer de
la lutté contre ligne ans avec une
expérience l'expérience ensemble avec d
autres qui centre au début être très
différents dit qu'à la fin si on est si
on peut les connaître
comme moi qu'on n'est pas si différent
c'est que m'intéresse c'est l'inconnu le
défi c'est toujours ça pour moins dans
un hall cc apprend comprendre le point
de vue d'un autre
daeninck connu sans le juger
comprendre temps en temps il ya un rôle
comme par exemple dans glee est
greenbook tony vallelonga c'est un homme
avec un personnage avec un un point de
vue très différents un ami c'est
intéressant et ça dans au début c'est
donc toujours un peu peur parce qu'on
sait pas comment va arriver un concombre
à transmettre son ce manque et s'en
tient jugé